hmm
donuts
the guiltiest of guilty pleasures
but where did the donut get its shape
and more specifically who put the hole
in the donut
two competing theories at the stage four
would become known as a great donut
debate
if you think of the quintessential
american sweet snack it is in fact the
donut that's michael crundle
he wrote this book the donut history
recipes and lore from boston to berlin
suffice to say cardinals what you call a
donut expert when you have something so
central to a culture as a donut is to
american culture you want to tell
stories around it
we here at great big story are no
exception
the first part of our story takes us to
1916 where a boston post reporter
interviewed hanson crockett gregory
gregory gives this long interview where
he explains how he invented it which was
that he was on board ship when he was
around 15 years old but he had the
clever idea of poking out the middle so
that the whole thing would cook evenly
this
he claims made him the columbus of the
donut hull
gregory's story spread like wildfire the
story was picked up by newspapers all
over the country this made him a star
it was a little unclear why they
believed the story of an 85 year old
sailor um
given the reputation sailors have
skepticism aside donuts grew more and
more popular over the years due in large
part to a donut dunking fat
donut dunking becomes a national
obsession in 1941 the national dunking
association yes a real thing hosted the
great donut debate where the question
was
who put the hole in the donut
[Music]
and one side of the debate was
the proposal that uh captain gregory had
in fact invented the donut hole as he
had explained which is as a youth on the
ship and on the other side chief high
eagle of the wampanoag tribe chief high
eagle had a completely different story
many generations ago
a member of his tribe was pursuing
a settler
and this settler apparently had a donut
in her hand and this young indian brave
shot an arrow which created a hole right
in the middle of the donut
in the end the celebrity panel awarded
gregory with the innovation
and though we can never prove that
hanson crockett gregory put the first
hole in the donut the tail lives on
you